what's up guys bang bang this was a big
big week in the Bitcoin Market first we
have Bitcoin hitting a 2023 high now
Bitcoin starting the year up 88 those
are big boy numbers but it's not just on
a global basis if you go and you look
around the world Bitcoin is hitting an
all-time high in Egypt that is because
the currency is being debased and
Bitcoin continues to do exactly what it
was designed to do now a big part of
what is driving the price appreciation
of 88 to start the year on that Global
Market is Blackrock and Larry Fink Larry
Fink recently went on television and he
had a lot to say about Bitcoin somehow
the CEO of BlackRock has become the
chief marketing officer of Bitcoin
here's a part of Larry's appearance and
you talk about how we're crypto fits
well I can't talk about Bitcoin because
we have a filing with the SEC so I'm
prohibited
I could talk about crypto in general and
I can talk about what we have done
you know we believe we have a
responsibility to democratize investing
and we've done a great job and and the
role of ETFs in the world is be is
transforming investing in it I think
we're only at the beginning of that I
mean we we believe the fixed income
Market is going to become multiple
trillion dollars in in
ETFs equities will continue more and
more the market will be
will be delivered through an ETF
platform
if you think about what was done 15 20
no 20 years ago now with the Advent of a
gold ETF
that's right that really democratized
gold investing it brought down the cost
of transaction go for gold I mean the
cost of transacting physical gold is
absurd
and now with crypto the idea of
democratizing that role the cost right
now to transact
is quite expensive we're talking points
not decimal points and so that's a big
point two
um over the last five years
more and more our Global Investors are
asking us about the role of crypto
and as I said I do believe a lot of
crypto is is going to be it's an
international asset
[Applause]
it's going it is uh
it has a differentiating value versus
other asset classes but more importantly
because it's so International it's going
to transcend any one currency in
currency evaluation if you just look at
the value of
of our dollar and how a depression last
two two months and how much it
appreciated over the last five years I
mean
a international crypto product can
really transcend that and that's why we
believe there's great opportunities and
that's why we're seeing more and more
interests and that interest is
broad-based worldwide and also I do
believe the role of crypto is
um it is it it's digitizing gold in many
ways it's a it's a instead of investing
in gold as a hedge against inflation a
hedge against the the onerous problems
of any one country or or the or the
devaluation of your currency whatever
country you're in
um
let's be clear Bitcoin is an
international asset it's not based on
any one currency and so it it can
represent a asset that people can play
as an alternative I would call the the
foundation of BlackRock is about hope
you invest for retirement because you
believe tomorrow is better than today
now we know BlackRock is not the only
organization that is filing for these
Bitcoin ETFs we also have Kathy Woods
Arc Fidelity Invesco and many many
others my guess is that the banging at
the door has gotten too loud and at some
point in the coming months we are going
to get that Bitcoin spot ETF approval
now one of the other reasons why this is
really important is that the amount of
Bitcoin that is sitting on exchanges
think about this as the free float or
something that people can come and buy
is only 11.5 percent this is nearing a
five-year low and so any time that you
have low liquidity in a market with 70
of Bitcoin in circulation not having
moved in a year and eleven and a half
percent of Bitcoin sitting on exchanges
and you couple that with a drastic
increase in demand that usually leads to
a higher price over time and so that 88
start to the beginning of the year may
not be the full story we still got the
second half of the year to go now of
course there's also a ton of excitement
because there's a judge in the United
States who has come out and said that
xrp is not a security the court filing
is complex there are times where the
sale of xrp by Ripple to institutions is
deemed a sale of unregistered Securities
but at the same time the sale on
exchanges or by executives are deemed
not a sale of Securities this is a big
deal because we are starting to get that
regulatory Clarity that everyone is
looking for and as we see exchanges
re-listing xrp that means that there's
going to be more and more investors who
say oh wait maybe that more clarity
means I can actually go ahead and
allocate to the industry some of that
Capital will flow into Bitcoin some of
that Capital will flow into other assets
ultimately more Capital flowing into the
industry given the market structure that
we currently are seeing with the
illiquidity should lead to higher prices
over time that's it for this week I hope
you guys enjoyed it I'll see you guys
next Saturday